wenn die ein stunden folge morgen nicht
kommt dann werde ich offiziell morgen
meinen kanal schließen da können wir
drauf wetten
hallo meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen zu einer neuen folge
minecraft galaxy nicht zu der ein
stunden folge ich wollte die eigentliche
gestern bringen das habe ich ja sehr oft
auch gesagt die sache war dann
allerdings dass ich quasi das gesagt
habe diese folge habe die aufgenommen
und habe das hochladen nicht
einberechnet also gestern nach der
folglich brauche mal drei stunden zum
hochladen
die folge hab ich so nachmittags
aufgenommen um 6 uhr so 18 uhr dann drei
stunden hochgeladen bis 21 uhr und hätte
ich dann noch die 50 m
die ein stunden folge aufgenommen dann
wäre ich quasi um 80 aufgenommen um 21
uhr fällig um 22 uhr fertig aufgenommen
da noch hochgeladen hätte werden das
irgendwie sieben stunden gewesen und da
ich ungern dem pc über nacht laufen
lassen möchte
weil da einmal hier schon mal ein kabel
angebracht ist und das war alles nicht
so witzig habe ich das ganze dann nicht
gemacht und ich war ja am nächsten tag
musste ich um halb fünf aufstehen weil
ich ja gestern gestern muss sich um 34
auf stehen weil ich nach london geflogen
bin ich hab da so eine eintages travel
schritt gemacht da habt ihr
wahrscheinlich auch fotos bei instagram
gesehen und da wird auch vermutlich
heute abend noch so ein langes video
kommen wobei meine london reise und ich
freue mich auf jeden fall schauen wie
das bei euch ankommt wird eine woche in
meinem leben kam auch schon bekannt
wahrscheinlich also es sind ja so follow
me round dann mehr oder weniger ich
denke euch gefällt das ganz gut ich
denke auch dass sonne wieder wird euch
gut gefallen weil ich viel von london
gelebt dann auch vieles was man nicht so
sonst so sieht also nicht nur
sehenswürdigkeiten sondern auch mal so
ecken und sonst nicht läuft da so einen
coolen restaurants habe ich mal gefehlt
weil ja auch schon sehr oft in london
war und erkennt man dann schon einige
coole eck wo man immer
dahingehend man ja das ist so coole
leute sind unser das tut mir auf jeden
fall total leiter waren wirklich leute
die mich aufs übelste beleidigt haben
dafür ich kann es nachvollziehen freude
das muss ich echt sagen ich kann
nachvollziehen wenn leute sagen ja eher
beleidigt immer nicht so leicht ein
anderes leben aber es tut mir wirklich
leid wenn ich hab's euch zwei mal
versprochen und habe zweimal nicht
eingehalten das tut mir extrem leid
deswegen möchte ich das quasi was heißt
wieder gut machen ich will diese woche
kommt jeden tag zwei videos also das ist
so mein aufruf jetzt hier weil ich die
ganze woche ich habe zwar stürmung und
entlassfeier und abi ball und muss mein
auto noch ummelden und muss noch zum
finanzamt und alles mögliche muss sich
zwar noch machen aber einfach als
entschuldigung dafür dass das jetzt
ganze nicht so kam wie ich mir
vorgestellt hab' ich rufe mal ganz kurz
meinem initiale zusammen damit die man
so ein bisschen weiter arbeiten hier
damit mir dann wieder von parrot
empfohlen keine platte begraben sich
jetzt mal bitte können sich dann
rheingraben di grassi wir wollen einfach
jetzt ein bisschen platz wo die organe
kommen ihre mitglieder beim dimmen da
bin
oder wie karbon ok verträglich auf
seinem kopf das ist das ist cool weil
ich doch mal kurz
wenn die taste z z die gemeinschaft ihr
grab das ganze bitte hier
sodann wo habe ich dann noch mal eine
kiste so hatte ich die denn da hatte ich
alle damit ich damit die mir so ein paar
während ich jetzt ein bisschen weiter
erzählt er mit dem ihr das ein paar
sachen einfach holen
ich packte man vergleicht meine stone
kiste vielleicht brauche ich sehr
irgendwann noch mal so dann packe ich
euch der ziele kiste hin so ein bisschen
als ausgleich halt so zwei videos jeden
tag ich hoffe ich kriege das hin das ist
so ein bisschen das ist für mich zwar
sehr sehr stressig aber ich muss jetzt
auch nicht treiben ich möchte nicht so
was lese ja du musst ihn nicht die
arbeit machen ist doch klar dass das
nicht klappen konnte mit 1 stunden folge
dass auch noch ein leben schreibt das
bitte nicht weil ich möchte euch
wirklich dafür das tut mir extrem leid
das möchte ich euch einfach nur so als
wiedergutmachung geben und die 1 stunde
voll bekommt am morgen als ich nehmt
jetzt im anschluss sogar auf wenn die
ein stunden folge morgen nicht kommt
dann werd ich offiziell morgen meinen
kanal schließen da könnt ihr drauf
wetten
die wird auf jeden fall kommen damit ihr
seht das jetzt kommt er jetzt hab ich
gesagt und jetzt wird es auch kommen so
die reliquien ach ja ich wollte mir den
den helm wollte ich mir reparieren
stimmt oder wie viel kostet 20 kostet 20
als nicht hat man für die reliquien rein
und ich wollte mir da die folge schon 4
minuten
ich habe mir wollten ein bisschen möbel
machen so ein paar coole sachen war dass
der chat ich mir schon gemacht habe ich
glaube schon
hatte ich wollte auf jeden fall unseren
spur machen so ein kleines tischchen
cher
aber das sind ja nun diese komischen
lassen das ist ob kraft
was hatten die da unten denn für stühle
das ist doch top craft oder beach area
das ist auch top craft ich wollte solche
spiele wo man sich richtig cool auch
hinsetzen kann welche erst mal ganz kurz
kennen
mit andré es ist scheißegal ob es nach
dem sonntag kann man das alles wird dann
hier noch alles wunderschön gemacht und
in der ein stunden folge werde ich dann
da unten meinen tollen meinen tollen
riesigen bereich hier machen
ich habe schon gedacht die ganzen
minions einfach immer hier hin zu ordern
hier dass die dann hier soll mein chef
timmer graben das mediale dass die mir
dabei so ein bisschen helfen quasi ich
weiß nicht genau wie ich das machen soll
andere meinte ich soll das komplett aus
glas hier unten bauen
wir nehmen aber auch noch nicht so ganz
sicher ob das gut aussieht naja muss ich
mal gucken ob ich habe ich glaube ich
habe hinten in den fluss oder jahre habe
ich noch relativ viele sachen drin ganz
anders aus hier aluminium liebt silva
und körper sowas hatte ich denn hierfür
stuhl ich hatte einen guten start aber
da konnte ich mich ja nicht drauf setzte
unglaublich
sitting is temporarily unavailable head
is built up und verfügbar so dann sollte
ich das jetzt mal ganz kurz noch das gut
darin limestone kein planer slams tolles
so die kisten hier werden wir
selbstverständlich auch noch in der
einen stunde sortiert ich habe ja so
super plan hier alles was hier nach
einstimmen folge machen möchte habe ich
alles aufgeschrieben
eine vorbereitet bin ich da wenn nur
noch nicht dazu gekommen das ganze
aufzunehmen ich habe so viele strawberry
stark freut mich mal schauen ob das mit
dem dings klappt wo ich hoffe das wird
was mit dem wenig reden doch dann habe
ich auf jeden fall so ein brocken
entziehen und helm ja und dann denke ich
werde ich mir sondern welchen job machen
nicht denn brot passt ganz gut
red bull und bamboo sticks habe ich
bambus tags erschwere skelette hier
überall
wir machen mit dem bamboo sticks europa
ganz kurz auch einfach zwei bamberger
beiden länder ich vier stück habe ich
nicht mal mehr muss ich hab die alle zu
diesem scheinbaren bundle gemacht ich
vollidiot was soll ich denn auch mit
bamboo bundle machen
mann mann mann luca da ist noch was
nehme ich euch da hinten einfach nur
noch mit
jetzt alle wieder da hat doch einfach
unten abschlagen können so dafür brauche
ich eigentlich gar nicht oder ist das
für alle möbel wichtig da mach ich mir
jetzt erstmal zwei chips oder noch ein
tipp einfach nur crazy gut sollen wir
die man mit meiner mit meiner dinks
abschießen kommen leute kommen aber
machen wir haben ja jetzt nicht so dass
wir unbedingt alles möglich erreichen
wollen
wie können wir auch mal ein bisschen
spaß haben
wohin der weg [ __ ] [ __ ] hält schon
geschossen wasser sehen
hallo keeper man richtig so gut leiden
kann
denn diesmal nach unten ab getroffen hat
aber schon eine krasse rüstung
ich finde überlegen ich verstehe die
ganze zeit meine munition
wer vielleicht ganz cool wenn ich mir
die einfach mal für den kampf aufbewahre
wenn jemandem kampf da oben ist das
skelett sagen wieso denn nicht getroffen
jetzt hab ich noch fünf munition aber
munition kann ich mir nachher noch
machen wollten ich war ganz witzig
können wir so ein bisschen mit dem a4 um
spielen da mach ich das mal eben so
bamboo sticks rote wolle habe ich dann
nicht roten farbstoff und wolle habe ich
nicht oder ich habe keine rolle habe ich
vor allem ich glaube ich auch katrin
wolle oder
ist allem liegt offen
so drei wolle dann mache wolle mit dem
farbstoff zudem ihr mache ich es packe
ich idiot wollten zwei spiele machen
aber heute noch mehr wolle
naja jedenfalls haben jetzt schon mal
einen scherz da kommen auf jeden fall so
meine ich nicht mehr hinter kommen noch
ein zweites bett dran dann kommt hier
auch so ich wollte das übrigens doch
nicht so krass hier alles mit sondern
das schlafzimmer soll schon so ein
bisschen privat gehalten werden sage ich
mal
man muss dann noch irgendwie coole leute
suchen weil die uns übrigens auch wieder
weiter gewachsen ist schon relativ bolt
und ist tot
mein dino ist tot aber egal ob topleute
mir ist egal aber ähnlich tamed von
nachher kanal und mein dino ist tot
okay das ist stark so stark traurig naja
so ausleben freunde denn die fressen und
gefressen werden wollte schon sagen
sterben und sterben lassen
keine ahnung wir kommen auf jeden fall
meinen bettchen hin dass sie wie ich das
cool einrichten kann
es gibt sie dann auch für coole sachen
dieses kleinod finde ich einmal noch
cool keine not place this cool aus ich
weiß nicht schreibt ihre ob das passt
ich hätte eher sowas dunkles jetzt sogar
gedacht sieht nicht so cool aus ich weiß
nicht was da sonst hin kann vielleicht
redwood planes ja die passen schon viel
besser als dieses helle eklige zeigt
sich dann von außen halte man noch so
ein bisschen doof aus weil da dann so
ein rohr baumes und dann sind da diese
komischen red wings doch das kann also
lassen
da kommt das hier noch so hin
da auch da muss ich halt schauen was ich
da mache ob ich da nicht eventuell doch
sein sohn lasse und da kommt jetzt die
fensterreihen oft allein da und dieser
herr tisch zeugs da wollte ich mir
eigentlich nochmal hier das so oft
trasse bauen
ich weiß jetzt dass mit dem glas und
nicht ein bisschen zu viel ist oder ob
ich mir da quasi so ein platz bauer
wo habe ich links
ein paar mode armut so wenn ich
theoretisch zwei von diesem chase habe
und ein table stadt ist viel wie sonst
nämlich kerry taylor cherry cherry usa
denn irgendwas was zu diesem jahr
eigentlich noch viel coolere stühle
ich brauche ihnen so einen diese hier
kann ich auf jeden fall nicht nehmen
weil die kann ich nicht mehr benutzten
tat handle die sind auch cool aus ich
denke ich war das ganze aus redwood baum
habe ich denn so hohen stühle habe ich
ein zwei wie kann ich diese stühle ob10
setzen kann ich auch so schräg setzen ja
kann ich auch dann packe ich mir da
irgendwie 2d vier stühle und ein tisch
aber ich habe hier keine mitte deswegen
ist das ein bisschen kacke miete kacke
blitz kacke oder ich mache das einfach
11 23
einfach so erstmal nein komme hierhin
kommt darin stellen stunde unter
vorkommt an sondern länglicher tisch
weil ich dafür broich sondern kaputt
oder irgendwie so ein länglicher hat
dich barry medley
hier kann sich seine fruchtschale machen
gefällt mir gefällt mir da kommt dann
die tische hin ja weiß nicht ich guck
mal ganz kurz auf mein helm was geworden
ist cool aus kann ich einfach super wenn
wir mit kritik muss die feuerwehr
beendet
moment das jetzt cool aus ja vielleicht
mit dem hält jetzt nicht ganz so geil
jetzt hier h weg niemand hätte noch
bestätigen weg dann ja cool das ist der
brocken entschied heim
man sieht wie man sie wie sie sehen
sehen sie nichts egal ist aber irgendwie
cool
meine ganzen teile da habe ich ihnen
verzauberung dadurch man die ganzen
teile daten sind mich in diesem punkt
verwandeln ich mal wieder zurück in der
fledermaus weiß ich nicht der gibt mit
genau da geht ein bisschen weniger als
der diamant helm
ich weiß nicht was er bringt schreibt
mir das mal wenn ihr das wisst ich lasse
ihn auf jeden fall erstmal aussortiert
mal ganz kurz das ganze hier zurück das
ist auf jeden fall cool das schon mal
geklappt hat ich werde mir dann in der
ein stunden folge morgen so ein paar
dinge machen wie mein haus weiterbauen
das ganze so ein bisschen schön machen
eine folge wo wir einfach beim themen
quatschen und jetzt fängt an zu regnen
natürlich super da setzen wir jetzt mal
ganz gewinn haben
dann werden wieder morgens ein bisschen
drüber quatschen ihr könnt mir dann auch
bei twitter fragen stellen und nachher
kommt nochmal london zusammenfassung
video was er zusammenfassen video so
alles was die neuen gefilmt habe und
dass hier denke ich auch relativ guter
sollte sich auf jeden fall dabei sein
letzter gefallen hat was die bewertung
da und wir sehen uns morgen wieder bis
gleich